how would you differentiate between
equity and equality
well the quality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer to that is
don't be to think of it you know uh
equality is equality of opportunity all
right we live in a society we want all
people right to have whatever color your
skin is equity I think is more guarantee
of outcome is it none
I think so I think that's okay so which
do you come which side do you come down
on
audio equality equality yeah okay
if you have any roughly approximately
sane Lefty in your family and they still
think Bernie is good or Bernie knows
what he's talking about show them that
clip he does not know the basics
this has got to end
we need Equity all equality equality
yeah okay
[Music]